[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
I'm sorry their elevator was out sorry
that probably looks weird it's time for
my warm-ups are gonna do this
[Laughter]
Hey Thievery no hey deep what kit yes
hey les
you think citizens now you just went to
a wearing camo and what's to stop
sergeant ham perfectly you think suits
now how many hijackers looks like three
they scrambled f-16s yeah as we but you
good you think sergeant homeland is now
wow this is amazing
alright I'm gonna get this this is good
[ __ ]
I don't care about the show I just want
a good blooper reel great that's all I
care about really welcome back everyone
is Charlie this is gonna be my new video
for the boys they just dropped a whole
bunch of deleted scenes ban jokes and
outtakes from the first season so we'll
break it down there's even some stuff
that was so hardcore that they couldn't
put it on this some crazy deleted scenes
that I'll talk about during the video if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I'll be
doing videos for all the boys season two
episodes because they changed the way
that they're gonna release the season
two episodes if you didn't see my
trailer video the other day it's coming
out September 4th
they're gonna drop the first three
episodes on the first day that it's out
then for all the rest of the episodes
for the season they're gonna release
them weekly so it'll just make a little
bit easier for me to do videos for all
the episodes I love home Landers quote
during that though just doing this for
the blooper reel just so they can get a
really badass blooper reel no other
reason to do this TV show there's a
whole bunch of homeland ER trying to
make it through his scenes a whole bunch
of the boys in butcher deleted scenes of
him just trying to make it through those
super long talks that he has in the big
speeches where he goes on and on about
the seven just cursing a storm up
dropping as many f-bombs as possible I
would say of all the characters on the
show the character who has the Fallas
mouth would be butcher but that's by
design he's written to be that way in
the comics there are a lot of characters
that they have changed for the TV show
like they made star light a little bit
different from her comic book self in
there a couple really WTF star light
scenes that didn't make it into the TV
show final cut really good example is
when she joins the seven for the first
time she's this wide-eyed country girl
she is super optimistic super religious
super goody two-shoes but then the rug
completely gets pulled out from under
her when the deep is like you better pay
me the sexual favor or else things are
gonna get really bad for you here really
fast it's meant to be this crazy moment
that they try to turn back around on him
later in the season so he sort of gets
his comeuppance but in the comic book it
was way worse in the comic book she had
to do that for every single male member
of the seven they all who stood
in a circle around her so of course
Amazon was like you cannot put this in
the TV show the other really not safe
for work scene that Amazon absolutely
made them cut was actually this home
Lander scene from episode 2 the way the
showrunner Eric Kripke talked about it
is that he said because the show itself
is so over to the top he was actually
surprised that Amazon wouldn't let them
do some things from the comic book what
originally happened was that during
episode two home leader gets yelled at
by Stillwell for the things that he did
at the end of episode one taking down
that plane with the politician in the
deleted scene after that he goes to the
Chrysler Building floating in mid-air
goes completely naked and starts getting
himself off just screaming I can do
whatever I want just letting this
business fly all over the city like it's
no big deal like nobody can touch him he
can do whatever he wants and that was
kind of a theme for his character during
season 1 I can do whatever I want
Anthony Starr the actor who plays
homeland was talking about how this
influences what happens during season 2
this is the clip of him talking about
that he was trying to find his way in
the world and it was very externally
focused right his oedipal complex was
fixed by the end of season 1 so season 2
is about dealing with the repercussions
about that but then it becomes a much
more internalized journey of you know
you've you've you've taken these big
strong actions into you know I could do
whatever the [ __ ] I want and killing
mummy figure and trying to take control
without you know with a sense of
autonomy and now you're gonna deal with
it so it really is very challenging for
him which makes it a very interesting
season so a lot of what's going on with
homeland during season two is just
dealing with the repercussions in the
next step now that he has actually
realized that he could literally do
anything that he wants because he pulled
off this big coup getting supers in the
military but I can't imagine Amazon ever
letting them release that homeland ER
scene so I wouldn't plan on ever
actually seeing it but they did actually
film the actor doing all those things
I love the clip here of the guy who got
his junk flash-frozen off when he slept
with a superhero that had cold based
powers that was one of the most WTF
funny moments like you feel bad for
laughing like it's kind of funny that
that happened to him but it's so messed
up for those of you asking about hero
gasm to talk about crazy deleted scenes
that would be the most epic of all
deleted scenes the
runner did say that they would actually
try and do a version of the hero gasm in
a future season but it sounds like it
didn't make it into season 2 unless I'm
mistaken the show has been renewed for
season 3 so maybe season 3 is some sort
of version of a hero gasm from the
comics if you don't know what hero gasm
is it's exactly what it sounds like
remember the idea that superheroes are
all kind of terrible people some of them
tried to do good things occasionally so
the hero gasm is an annual convention
that they all hold internally with the
superhero community and it's basically
like the worst version of spring break
that you could possibly imagine
imagine what Spring Break would be like
with no consequences with a bunch of
super-powered people just doing whatever
they felt like I suppose there's a
toned-down version of that that you
could do but if you want to get the full
dose of it like the full WTF version
just read the comic book because the
comic book is way way worse in terms of
graphic nature than what you see on the
TV show
there were some other deleted scenes
that they dropped during the season and
some fake promos like there was a scene
of the deep filming a fake advertisement
for some charity work but it's mostly
him just being a douche bag it's not
quite as crazy as some of the stuff
during this blooper reel and deleted
scenes
itadakimasu nothin Oh GCO you ghetto but
let me know in the comments what are
some moments from the comic book that
you hope that they do during the boys
season - or season 3 and if it wasn't
clear yes they have been renewed for
season 3 I don't know when they're gonna
start filming that but the Marvel people
in the DC people are mostly starting to
film stuff by the end of July
speaking of Anthony star in homeland err
I know a lot of people want him to play
reverse-flash in the upcoming flash
flashpoint movie for DC the only thing
getting in the way of something like
that would be scheduling conflicts with
the boys filming episodes so he has a
long-term contract with Amazon for the
boys they'll be doing multiple more
seasons hopefully they'll make it to
five or six seasons he would make an
amazing version of reverse-flash in the
DC Universe just a complete psychopath
but the one thing that could prevent
that from happening would be scheduling
conflicts with the boys season 3
episodes because they're supposed to
start filming the flash movies sometime
early next year so don't be too bummed
out if he doesn't wind up being the
movie version of reverse-flash I'm sure
whoever they wind up getting for that
role will be suitably crazy as you would
expect them to be while you wait for
everything click here for the opening
scene from the boys season 2 episode 1
and click here for that full season 2
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]